this is the aftermath of California's
deadliest and most destructive wildfire
eighty-five people died here in a fire
that PG&E the country's largest utility
is suspected of starting now PG News
filed for bankruptcy which pauses any
lawsuits brought by survivors and that
means those who've lost everything might
get nothing at all this is a story about
a deadly catastrophe so you survived
developing July and what happens when
the government puts the interests of a
corporation about public over people
[Music]
this is what used to be my home my
husband and I moved in here over a year
ago though months have passed since the
camp fire destroyed paradise survivors
like Jena Darby are still searching for
anything they're able to recover I'm
very hopeful that they find my race I
have a antique ring that was gifted to
me when I graduated high school and a
ring that my mother made from the
diamonds from her wedding ring to my
death Pacific Gas & Electric or PG&E has
admitted that its equipment was probably
the cause of the campfire an employee
reportedly spotted flames at a utility
tower in the area the same location that
Cal Fire which is investigating the
blaze has identified as a start of it
all that tower is part of a century-old
high voltage transmission line that PG&E
knew as a safety hazard and intended to
overhaul for five years but didn't and
that's the fundamental problem PG&E is a
privately owned corporation that answers
to its shareholders and Wall Street
lenders not members of the public like
seventeen-year-old Katia whose home was
completely destroyed in the campfire
that was my Grammie sauce that was I was
never supposed to change that I was
always supposed to be the same you know
it's like it was the one thing that
stayed the same throughout my entire
childhood and now it's gone on the
morning of the fire Katia was
house-sitting for a friend when she woke
up to intense smoke the next thing she
knew firefighters were throwing her in
the back of a truck yeah it was pitch
black that you could not see through any
of the smoke and there was fire
everywhere and we pulled up onto this
bridge and the fireman said get out
Katya jumped into this river with 14
others and took shelter for several
hours as flames surrounded her I
couldn't do anything except for a scream
it was just looking around it was just I
thought I was gonna die all of this was
on fire even the leaves on the water
we're burning everything was just so
intensely hot and at one
why I just kind of leaned back in the
water and I just floated out over there
and I just kind of said okay if this is
how it happens and this is how you want
to take me I'm ready for ruling I know
that someone is at fault and I would
like to say that it's most likely P
genies negligence that causes but I
don't like to be like oh let's get angry
at the PG&E guys because they you know
they started this it's like I'm sorry
that they work for a bigger corporation
you're talking about how it's unfair to
attack the PG&E workers who are up there
trying to fix things but what about the
giant corporation that's worth building
take responsibility take ownership and
help those people that you have hurt
that's the least that you can do in all
of this and all the mistakes you've made
you can at least make some right and
they've made it very clear that they
won't
in the next town over California
Governor Gavin Newsom met with children
displaced by the campfire he was elected
just days before the fire and during his
campaign he accepted over 200 thousand
dollars from PG&E there's a growing
demand among ratepayers that I've spoken
to that PG&E be truly publicly owned is
that something you'll support is
government truly publicly owned right
now we're just trying to figure out how
to deal with the immediacy which is the
need to make sure we have safe
affordable and reliable service make
sure we get through this bankruptcy in a
way that protects ratepayers protects
the victims make sure the victims are
made whole how will you hold them
accountable if they're found responsible
for the campfire well they're gonna be
held accountable because that letter of
the law we're gonna hold them to account
could hold an account to make sure that
the victims are made whole we're gonna
hold them account to make sure they're
doing everything to mitigate against any
future disasters but PG and E was
already on criminal probation in 2010 a
PG&E gas line exploded and killed eight
people the company was convicted on six
criminal charges and fined 1.6 billion
dollars by the state for failing to
maintain its pipeline system from 2014
to 2017 PG&E power lines and equipment
were responsible for sparking 1500
wildfires across California then in 2018
the California State Legislature passed
a bill allowing PG&E to pass the costs
of the 2017 fires to its customers three
months later the camp fire happened
several things went wrong before the
camp fire broke out a big issue is that
power lines in wooded areas like
Paradise tend to get caught on trees and
PG&E which services 70,000 square miles
across California insisted doesn't have
the manpower required to trim all the
trees but what they could have done is
shut off power to customers as a safety
precaution in fact they even said they
would two days before the campfire PG&E
warned customers that they might shut
off power but they didn't even though it
appears that all of the factors for a
shut off were at play in an email PG&E
told me the conditions that day did not
meet their criteria but declined to
elaborate
we're in the middle of reporting on this
PG&E story and we heard about another
gas explosion that just occurred in San
Francisco so we're on the way to check
out the scene the initial reports
indicate that this was a third-party dig
in related to a construction project and
not any way associated with Dijonnaise
but until PG&E turns off the gas the
fire can't be put out and they have a
reputation for being slow well during
the last explosion in 2017 it took PG&E
three hours to turn off the gas do you
think that's acceptable as I mentioned
we are number one priorities the safety
of the public customers and servant of
our communities so we're gonna work as
hard as possible safely and quickly as
possible to get this situation you agree
it should be turned off ASAP
I definitely agree that we will work as
quickly as possible do everything we can
to ensure the safety of our customers
the San Francisco residents it's been
over two hours since the gas explosion
and we just heard a press conference
during which the PG&E spokesman really
had no information to offer other than
the fact that this was not caused by
PG&E but he couldn't tell us when the
gas line would be cut and until that
happens this is still a very active
situation in the end no one was hurt but
five buildings were destroyed PG&E
claims all of its lines were properly
marked before a crew working for Verizon
started digging underground but in 2018
an investigation by the California
Public Utilities Commission the state
agency responsible for regulating PG&E
found the company falsified internal
records on gas pipeline safety over a
five-year period
at a CPUC meeting held days after PG&E
declared bankruptcy ratepayers blasted
the agency for approving PG news request
to borrow six point 1 billion dollars
from the state the CPUC has come under
fire for what critics say is the
agency's refusal to make PG&E put safety
over profits and for its cozy
relationship with the
multibillion-dollar corporation
democratize if the plan is structured in
such a way as to prioritize paying off
the big investors and the big companies
first and not the survivors then this is
a I think a terrible insult to the
memories of the survivors protesters
like Seth Sanders believe that because
PG&E is providing a public service the
company should in fact be public there
is no reason that the state can't just
buy PG&E over the next year and make
sure that it truly serves Californians
why do you think they wouldn't so if you
look at who is on the CPUC board and you
look at who's worked for energy
companies there's a lot of overlap you
can't just pay your friends you can't
just pay your already super-rich
investors you have to take care of the
people first who do you blame for this
tragedy I blame the big corporations the
big oil the the utilities along with the
fossil fuel industry have been lying to
us in covering it up for the last 30
years PG&E does not have the right to
kill people for profit after repeated
requests the CPUC PG&E and governor
Newsome's office all declined my
requests for an interview but I still
had questions
Eugenie's headquarters and I've asked
them several times for an interview
before this they won't give it to me but
I still want to know why didn't they
turn off the power on the day of the
fire and why did this
multibillion-dollar corporation keep
delaying necessary repairs on a
transmission line near paradise for
years
hi how are you I'm here to see Blair
Joanie
okay Blair Jones please there boom Blair
Jones our spokesman we've been in touch
over email beginning
who's your new spokesman lawyer Tony Oh
sir stop
why you can sum it and that's the okay
these are my colleagues are gonna come
you have to stay for a while allow me to
cover PG&E would not let me speak with
anyone there security gave me a business
card and showed me the door okay thank
you
[Music]
the campfire had catastrophic effects on
the environment for weeks toxic air
choked parts of Northern California and
at points we were dealing with the worst
air quality in the world on the same day
of the campfire the Woolsey fire
scorched Southern California oh my god
cease to kill I don't let me die please
don't let me die in the face of growing
climate change which PG&E points to as a
culprit in the wildfires I wanted to
know what can be done to prevent such
catastrophes mark Jacobson is an expert
in renewable energy and is consulting on
the green New Deal how much is climate
change a factor when you look at the
magnitude of the fires California has
been having lately climate change is
definitely a factor and intensifying
fires and even allowing some of them to
occur or to spread we have to address
global warming certainly on a large
scale and the way to do that is to
transition to clean and renewable energy
for all purposes so if you were tasked
with helping to rebuild paradise and set
up the energy there what would you be
doing I would make it so it's a
completely electric efficient community
running primarily on solar and wind in
California there's a law that by 2020
all new homes have to be zero net energy
they have to basically produce as much
energy that they consume in the annual
average
it could take up to a decade to rebuild
paradise PG&E has stressed it'll do more
safety shut offs as part of a new
wildfire prevention plan its CEO has
stepped down with a payout of 2.5
million dollars the company is also
trying to give out 235 million in
bonuses this year all while the campfire
survivors are waiting to see what
they'll receive and as wildfires become
the norm in California the state has yet
to hold the corporation accountable to
the public it serves there is somebody
up there in the chain of command making
these decisions and being totally fine
with it but at least take ownership for
the fact that you provided the service
and ended up hurting thousands hey guys
it's Deena here at PG News headquarters
thanks for watching this episode about
how corporate negligence can kill people
let me know what you think about PG&E in
the comments be sure to like this video
and share it and if you like this
reporting make sure to LIKE the direct
from playlist I'll see you next time